If you've ever received an email that says "Join my network on LinkedIn,"...
...you've probably wondered, "What is LinkedIn?"
A simple answer is that it's the world's largest professional network,...
...helping people find and share opportunities every day.
But how is it relevant to you?
Managing your career is just one reason to join LinkedIn.
As you develop your professional profile,...
...you establish an authoritative resource on your experience and capabilities...
...that lets people find you when they search the Internet.
In two minutes, you'll be up and running...
...with the most important page on the web you'll ever have.
Do you know what people find when they google your name?
With LinkedIn, you'll have more control over what appears in Google results,...
...and having a robust profile encourages people to approach you with opportunities.
Many of your contacts are already on LinkedIn,...
...and you can reconnect just by uploading your address book.
This lets you stay in touch even as your contacts change jobs and email addresses.
Your reputation is summed up by the relationships you've developed over your career.
LinkedIn helps you maintain these relationships authentically.
In addition, when you want to make new business connections,...
...you can find people using LinkedIn's search tool...
...then see who you know in common.
This makes it easy to request an introduction from your trusted connections.
You can also join a LinkedIn group,...
...where professionals in your field discuss issues...
...and solve problems related to your industry.